okay it's that time of year again extra
life's on in like two days we usually do
a trailer there is no time to do a
trailer so we're just going to have to
record this in one go um maybe just look
at make it look a little bit nice put
the logo somewhere and drop a fat
beat die Germans die for the children
die for the children the first year we
did this 24 games from 24 years and 24
hours you might remember super lowii in
my house we had a bunch of fun raised
like 8 Grand last year we did 50 games
uh we had Gamespot Au and Gamespot us
and UK all doing it together in a row I
think we me for 72 in the end thank you
very much Jess McDonald raised over 20
grand this year 100 hours 100 games
we're swapping it every single hour
we're going to use the uh polls in
gamespot.com chat to swap up the game
every time so you guys choose and our
goal this year is 20 grand all you have
to do is go to gamespot.com for/ ja
starting tomorrow Wednesday the 22nd of
October at noon
Pacific
on the screen right now is all the
different times that it's on in your
local area uh we're going to do 24 hours
in the US and it's going to go 24 hours
in the UK and then 24 hours in Australia
and then it's going back to us office
I'm going to do 28 hours here to rent it
up to 100 uh we need your help tin
url.com GS extra life or as I have
subsequently realized now that I have
that URL gextra life just go to that
donate watch the show uh tell your
friends tell your mom hide your children
uh hide your wife
actually there's lots of other stuff
happening I think Jess is doing all of
the Au on her own currently um I know
there's a Gta diary's Live being done
from the UK I think there's some sort of
special guest happening uh we're going
to have a really weird night on the US
one on Wednesday where everyone's
getting drunk for some reason but I
can't tell you about H and then we're
yeah going to do it on the weekend so
that's the 22nd of October noon we're
going to do it for 100 hours 100
hours it's PR bad idea see you there
n